[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to another
end game video i'm both nervous and
excited maybe a little bit more nervous
than excited because today's video
actually marks the initiation of our
journey into the end game the video that
came out a couple of days ago uh was
meant to inspire you was meant to set
the tones at the table
and help us understand why it's even
worth studying endgames and uh to help
us realize that end games are worth
studying both from the perspective of
becoming stronger and also from the
perspective of appreciating a very
unique kind of beauty that occurs in end
games but today we get our hands dirty
our hands dirty we begin our journey
into pawn and games
and uh it's going to be the start of
what i hope to be
a very productive and very fun
journey indeed
so
at first i kind of hesitated
you know with what to start because
there's so many concepts to talk about
and i want to remind everybody that the
structure of these endgame videos and i
won't keep saying this at the start of
every video i'm just going gonna remind
everybody one more time
we're gonna start with a couple of
videos that break down
uh the basic concepts of each type of
end game pawn end games night end games
bishop and games etc and note that these
concepts build off of each other and
that is why we are starting with pawn
end games because the concepts you have
to understand in order to master pawn
enemies are really the basic concepts of
all end games that they're all
encompassing
and after we examine all of those
concepts there will be a few videos
where we put those concepts together and
actually learn how to play complex end
games
and uh i didn't hesitate about which
concept to start with because there is
one concept that is the king of all
concepts no pun intended uh with respect
upon end games if you don't understand
this idea this concept then you
cannot make any progress toward
understanding more complex uh phenomena
and that is of course
as you know from the title of the video
the past pawn
all right let us begin let me switch
scenes
and here we go
so the past pawn
is what i would refer to as the basic
currency of pawn end games and of all
end games in general but again in this
video we restrict ourselves to
pawn and games
learning pawn enemies without
understanding past pawns is kind of like
trying to learn economics without
knowing what money is or like what a
dollar is it's virtually impossible to
win a pawn end game without at some
point creating at least one past pawn
now let's start as we always will with a
couple of definitions and
the next couple of sort of the next
discussion might seem to you very basic
very rudimentary might question whether
it's necessary but i argue that getting
the definition down very clearly and
understanding you know sort of gray area
cases and edge cases will really help us
maximize uh our learning process and
make our learning more efficient if we
know what we're talking about at all
times
then there's no misunderstanding and
because there are so many concepts that
are unique to the end game i think it's
very important to nail down the
definition before we go any further now
oddly enough the merriam-webster's
dictionary has a pretty darn good
definition of what a pass pawn is
passpon is a chess pawn that has no
enemy pawn in front of it on its own or
an adjacent file
okay so let's break that down for a
second a chest pawn we know that we're
playing chess that has no enemy pawn so
in order to determine whether a pawn is
passed you have to look at uh the
opposing pawns uh with one very small
exception that we're going to get to
later on its own or an adjacent file
what does that mean that means when you
are trying to determine whether a pawn
is passed you look strictly in front of
it anything that is behind the pawn is
totally relevant because pawns move
forward so if there's an enemy pawn
on the same file in front of your pawn
that has nothing to do with whether the
pawn is passed
let's take a look at a couple of simple
examples you will see that the kings are
missing and that is by design the kings
are going to be irrelevant as we discuss
definitions and i will do this often i
want to pare things down
so that there are as few distractions as
possible so which pawns are passed
assuming these are all of the pawns on
the board which of them are past well
all of them right the g pawn has no
obstructions they can move forward c
pawn has no obstructions and neither
does the apon all of the pawns are
passed that is simple enough
now let's add a little bit of spice this
example might seem a little confusing to
you always remember
um i will help you by drawing arrows to
indicate which way the pawns are going
white is going forward
whichever side we are facing you can
assume that the pawns of that side are
going forward you know the white pawns
are never going to be going backward if
we're facing facing white and which of
the pawns are passed here and reading
the definition you might get a little
bit confused wait a minute the pawns are
on the same file but again that has
nothing to do with it because the black
pawn is behind the white pawn and
correspondingly the white pawn is from
black's perspective behind the black
bond so all four of these pawns are in
fact passed because they have absolutely
no obstructions white can push either
one of them
and black and push either one of his or
her passers as well right so very
important you have to look in front of
the pawn
one more clarifying example let's take a
look at this position and here perhaps
you can pause the video
and identify which of whites and blacks
pawns are in fact passers and before you
do that i will use past pawns and
passers interchangeably pastor is just a
shortened way of saying pass pawn so i'm
going to usually say that
so passer passed on exactly the same
thing i'll give you a couple of moments
to think about which pawns are passed
here
and now
the only reason i do this is that i can
guzzle down my coffee as i'm making this
video okay so let's start with white
well is the a pawn passed at first you
might think it is but in fact it's not
black as a pawn on the adjacent file
adjacent meaning one file to the right
one file to the ref to the left to the
left and the b pawn is of course in
front of the a pawn so when white's pawn
reaches a5 it can be captured that means
the apon is not passed the b-pawn
obviously not passed because again black
has a
b6 pawn that stands in front of it the c
pawn is passed right no no obstructions
in front of it the e pawn is not passed
because there is a d-pawn on the
adjacent file and the same goes for the
g-pawn there is an f-bond on the
adjacent file controlling the g6 square
right this is simple enough on the black
side the b-pawn is not passed the d-pawn
is also not passed white has an e-pawn
on an adjacent file that is controlling
the d5 square
f7 same thing right there's a kind of a
reflection going on here if the white
pawn is not passed then the black pawn
does not pass for much the same reason
and the h pawn is black's only passer
because there are
no obstructions okay so very very simple
here it's an intuitive definition the
only gray area case um and i did some
research on this is a situation where
there are doubled or tripled pawns are
the pawns that i highlighted in red
considered paths right there is no enemy
pawn in front of them but there's your
pawn in front of them what i found on a
website called chess programming that is
designed to help people program chess
computers they claim that these pawns in
red are not passed and i kind of
intuitively agree with that idea right
the spirit of a passport is that you
should be able to push it um until
promotion and you literally cannot push
these other pa other pawns
in the previous video the inspiration
video i did refer to double pawns um as
all being passed but from now on
if we will get these cases which are
going to be very rare
um then i will not refer to these
you know the second pawn in a doubled
pawn situation as past only the green
pawn here is strictly speaking past and
if it promotes yeah then uh then the c3
pawn becomes passed and if that bomb
promotes and the c2 pawn becomes fast
you get the point
okay now that we have the definition
down let's start getting to the meat we
know what a passpond is
how do you create one like great fast
pawns are great how do you make one well
that's also simple enough there are two
methods that we are going to concern
ourselves with in this video there is a
third method that uh we'll have an
entire video dedicated to it that is
pawn breakthrough and i will talk a
little bit about that here just to let
you know what that is but that is
important enough of a concept in partner
games that it requires its own entire
video
the first method is what i call the king
capture method it's where your king
captures the enemy pawns that are
obstructing one of your pawns and when
you do that your pawn becomes pass again
all of this none of this is supposed to
be tricky all of this is supposed to be
very intuitive so in this position it's
white to play white's going forward
well the c pawn is not passed because
black has actually two pawns that are
obstructing its path so white's king
travels
toward black's pawns captures them and
then the sea pawn becomes past now
there's a little exercise worked in this
um
in this position and it's designed to
give you a sneak preview of the concept
of pawn breakthroughs so your task is to
tell me whether king d4
or king d5 both win the game or does
only one of them win the game
so pause the video
take a couple of moments to think about
that where would you go with your king
does it even matter
and another sip of coffee for me
okay
so the answer is that you actually have
to go king d4 to win the game king d5
looks like exactly the same thing but
black has a pawn breakthrough here black
can play the move b4
and this is essentially what a pawn
breaker is also a very simple concept
but a simple concept to define but not
to apply and that's why uh it'll it'll
have its own video the point is that you
sacrifice upon in order to create uh one
of your own passers now white can draw
the game by taking this pawn and then
you end up with bear kings the way that
king d4 prevents this is that it
controls the c3 square so black can play
b4 but it's not going to help because
you're just going to capture uh this
technically is a passer but you're going
to capture it on the next move it's life
will be very short-lived if black tries
to bring his own king down he loses the
race king c5 king takes b5 and just in
the nick of time
you're able to take the c4 pawn and this
is a winning
this is a winning pawn end game i
haven't fully decided yet whether i will
be making videos on theoretical end
games and games that you should kind of
know and remember this being one of them
king and pawn versus king and games i
probably will but that will all be done
separately um that is of course
something that you can learn but
resources on theoretical end games are a
lot more plentiful
than resources on just understanding
endgames as a whole so stay stay tuned
for that i'll let you know whether uh
whether videos on this will be coming as
well but that's beside the point the
point is that this is the king capture
method you use your king to take uh your
opponent's pawns
more commonly
you use just your pawns to create a
passport and that is what i call the
pawn advance method not particularly
original names but it gets the job done
that is where you have a pawn majority
and you use that pawn majority to uh
create a pass pawn this is incredibly
intuitive as well let's take a look at
an example you have b and a versus b
that's a pawn majority it's a two on one
how does white create a pass pawn out of
it simple enough well you identify the
pawn that is ultimately going to be
passed
and it's usually the one that's located
adjacent to where the obstruction is so
in this case the a pawn is the one that
is going to ultimately be passed and
then you push it you play a4
let's say black tries to get his king
closer and then you play
a5
black can trade black can ignore it
doesn't matter
a5 this is already
a past pawn this is another slight
grayer like do we call this pawn pass
right now or is it only passed now i
think we call it past at this exact
moment because its path toward promotion
is unobstructed
um okay so black takes for example you
take back
and as a matter of fact black is unable
uh to stop the pawn by a couple of tempe
white promotes to a queen
now there are of course some pitfalls it
would not be advisable to go b5 in a
situation like this in this particular
instance b5 wins the game but that's
beside the point you can see what the
problem is the problem now is that in
order to create a passport you are going
to have to sacrifice one of your pawns
and often allow your opponent to create
a passport of their own which is
generally speaking less advisable than
than not doing that so that's the pawn
advance method
now
in order to fully understand upon
advanced method you have to understand
the ppp rule
um and the ppp rule all of it you know
done in my in my own laboratory and
these might be awkward names but
hopefully will help you remember things
uh ppp stands for push the prospective
passer not perspective but prospective
like the pawn that's going to become the
passer that's just what i talked about
right
in terms of which pawn to start pushing
you want to start pushing the pawn that
ultimately will end up being
the passer and i think this was first
formulated by aaron nimsovich who was a
very famous chess thinker and obviously
very strong chess player who wrote a
book called my system i think in the
early 20th century
so looking at this position which pawn
is going to become the passer as i said
in the last example it's going to be the
pawn
that has no direct obstructions that is
no obstructions on the same file in this
case it's the g pawn and so that is the
pawn
that you push you go g4
now
i should have put a king here because it
would have allowed me to make more moves
i wanted to like pass let's say black
passes
then you're going to go either g5 that
works you go g4 g5 then you bring the h
pawn up to h5 and you go g6
or
you can actually go h4 and then g5 and
then h5
now
why doesn't that matter and what matters
in this case well what happens if you
play h for first why is that so bad well
that's bad because it creates the
situation i just outlined and i've heard
the situation referred to i don't
remember where it might have been in
chesschess.com
um
i've heard it referred to as the deep
freeze and i really like that name the
deep freeze occurs for some reason
it's not letting me move the black
pieces that's fine uh because i have
another example waiting the deep freeze
occurs when
when a pawn minority is essentially
fully controlling and dominating over a
pawn majority so black will play h7h5
here
and um let me see if i can uh
oh actually no i
yeah for some reason it well i mean it's
fine black will play h5 and as you can
see just like in the other example i
showed white cannot create a passer
without sacrificing one of his pawns in
this case
now let's look at a dedicated deep
freeze example
look at this position for a moment
it's white to play now
white has four pawns black s2 it looks
like a completely winning position and
it is but the only thing you have to be
careful about is that black's king is
clearly very active and it's very close
to white's pawn so you can't dilly dally
and
a lot of players and this is perhaps one
of the most common mistakes in pawn end
game so listen carefully
a lot of players understand conceptually
the deep freeze but they still fall for
it so you might look at this and say
well i need to create a past pawn before
black's king gets to my pawns and that
logic is correct well the fastest way to
create a password is to go g3 followed
by h4
no no no no no that is wrong black plays
g4 and you're caught in a deep freeze
where one pawn controls three this is a
very common type of structure we will
see it again and amazingly black
actually wins the game despite wiping
two pawns down because if white pushes
the pawn black on pissants and black's
passer is much closer to promotion
and if white tries to go after black's
king
sorry black's b-pawn black actually just
plays king c3 the pawn is perfectly
capable of taking care of all of white's
pawns and black is able to dedicate his
efforts to winning the b3 pawn by
playing the move pawn before this is
zooxbang which we will introduce later
as well the king has to drop back black
wins the pawn and you can convince
yourself of the fact that black wins the
game
i wanted to add one little tangent which
is that yes
as i do the video you will hear concepts
and terms and words that will later have
their own dedicated videos that is to
some degree inevitable right i can't
fully avoid self-reference i can't fully
avoid using concepts that i haven't
introduced yet
after a couple of videos after we get
our feed under us
you'll be aware of everything and the
situation will not arise again but just
bear with me if i introduce a term that
you know that i haven't talked about yet
i'll try to kind of define it very
briefly so you know what i'm talking
about but you should be able to gather
everything from context so very
important rule ppp push the prospective
passer and avoid the deep freeze
now creating a passer
still might sound very easy but it gets
harder when you've got more pawns like
in a two on one pawn majority situation
creating a passer is generally very
straightforward but when we add more
pawns when we have a three on two even
the process is a lot harder and it's a
lot more cumbersome it takes more moves
let's take a look at this position so
how does white create a passer here well
again i should have probably added kings
to the board because it would would have
allowed me to move pieces but uh it's
okay for this one we can visualize
things in our head
so
it's not even clear what the perspective
passer is but using our rule we can
determine that is there a pawn that has
no pawn directly in front of it yes it's
the f-bomb so that's going to be our
passer
so
do we push the perspective passer we can
play f4 that is one way of creating the
password we play f4
then we do not play h3 because that
allows a deep freeze situation
with h4 so that makes sense black plays
h4 that's a deep freeze so what we want
to do is we want to push f4
then we play g3 to stop h4 only then do
we play h3 then we play g4 and f5 that's
one two three four five moves that's a
staggering amount of moves until a pass
pawn can be created there is an
alternative method you can play h4 first
yes that's a violation of the rule you
don't push the perspective pastor but
you kind of deep freeze black's pawns
and can you pause the video and find
what the subsequent moves are this is
actually a more efficient method
coffee time for me
okay
so
the method is to play f3 and then g4
if black takes then you create a past h
pawn if black doesn't take then you are
the one to take and then you push your f
pawn all the way forward so
with a three on two more moves are
required but it's still relatively
straightforward and the rules still hold
continuing
the question of how to create pastors of
course very often your king has to be
involved in order to break a deep freeze
situation right let's consider this
position very quickly it's white to play
can white create a passer on the king
side well it's a three on two but it's a
deep freeze because black is controlling
the g4 square with two pawns and the
answer is that yes you can create a
password but you'll need the assistance
of your king you need to play the move
h3
okay it doesn't matter where black goes
say black moves his king and rather than
going g4 you start by bringing your king
up to f3
black chills and then you play g4 so you
use your king to create a passer
and after the trade voila we have our
past f-pawn
so
now we talked about how to create past
pawns right also pretty straightforward
the king capture method
the pawn advance method we talked about
ppp
uh we i cautioned you against avoiding
the deep freeze and we talked about
using the king to uh set up a trade that
creates a passer
now look at the position that's in front
of you
let's transition to a separate example
that is dedicated to that position this
is going to segue us into our next topic
which is going to be to classify past
pawns right past pawns come in many
different shapes and sizes in fact there
are five special types of past pawns you
have to understand each and every one of
them very very carefully in order to
fully master the concept of past pawns
now obviously there are passpons that
don't fall in either of those five
categories in fact most of them don't
but these five categories refer to very
special types of passports you'll see
what i mean once we start defining them
and the first and perhaps most important
type is the outside pass pawn
now the outside pass pawn is formally
defined as the passer on the leftmost or
rightmost file
relative to the other passers and
relative to the other pawns if there's
only one passport on the board then
obviously it is by definition a con a
outside passer
but the spirit of the definition is that
an outside passer is a pawn that's very
far away from the other pawns and what
that tries to describe is that
that passer is going to distract the
enemy king and you are going to use your
king to walk around and take the pawns
on the other side of the board that is
why
an outside passer is so dangerous it is
one of the greatest assets that you can
have in the end game and we will see a
situation where both sides have a passer
but because one side has an outside
passer it's just an easy win the passers
are not even comparable in
their power so let me describe that
method here
through this example how does white win
this position well if you know king and
pawn uh
king and pawn versus king and games
pretty well you'll know that if we
remove the apons from the board this is
a draw
uh if you don't you can just sort of
take a little detour set this up on a
board and uh try to work out why it's a
draw but with the pawns white wins quite
straightforwardly how does white win
well
you don't play f5 that's the one thing
you don't want to do because this as
you'll see creates a bird and white has
to keep this pawn protected instead what
you want to do is walk around you go
king f3 you don't need to push the pawn
that's not the point the point is just
to use the pawn as a decoy king f5 king
e3
now black has to step back
and this is where we make a run for it
boom king b4 run run run run run run
black has to take the pawn run run run
run
and we win by a tempo black almost makes
it to the promised land
no no no this is called shouldering this
will also be in a video we stop black's
king from reaching the c file and now
the red carpet is unrolled we push the
pawn forward once again to the promised
land so let me just repeat that really
fast because i know i went quickly we
use the pawn as the decoy and therefore
the further the pawn is away from the
enemy king the better that's why outside
passers often should not be pushed
pushing them can often be a very bad
idea because it uh closes the distance
between the enemy king and the outside
pastor that's why instead we just walk
our king toward black's pawns uh black
pawn and we let black
waste time to capture our outside passer
that is
one of the most important winning
methods in pawn end games in subsequent
videos where we put stuff together you
will see that method in action
slightly more complicated example but
the same spirit here we've added a past
pawn for black
now currently
definitionally the c5 font is the
outside password because it's the only
password but that's a meaningless
statement it's a meaningless statement
because as you can see there's a two on
one that's further away from all of the
other pawns that means white has the
capacity to create his own outside
passer and win the game he does that by
playing h3
black has no choice but to play can you
find that g4 would be hasty first you
want to go king c4 and drag black's king
back
now you go g4 and we are already
familiar with the situation after king
c6 in this case you do push your outside
password because you have to incentivize
the opposing king
to leave this side of the board you can
just play g6 and uh this isn't even
black's king is literally not even close
uh you can just go king c7 and then push
your pawn down to promotion
outside pass pawn type one
type two is the protected past pawn the
protected pass pawn is very
self-explanatory i won't dwell too long
on the definition it's a pass bond
that's protected by another pawn right
not by a king by another pawn protected
past pawns are
in many cases equally or even more
dangerous than outside passers because
when you have a protected pass pawn what
that essentially means is that in most
cases you don't have to supervise that
pawn with your king you could use your
king to attend to other business the
pawn is entirely self-sufficient and if
the opposing king tries to capture the
root of the protected passer then that
pawn advances forward that's what's so
satisfying about that situation
black tries to take on e3 you get that
f1 all the way down the board
a quick example from one of my games
uh this was a game that i played with
white many many years ago i was actually
1800 and i played this game
notice that white is upon up and the
fastest way to win this game with white
is to convert the d-pawn into a
protected passer with d4 check
we have the situation and now we can use
our king to go after black spawns we
have king b4 king c6 king a5 king b7 and
now the um
protected passer is essentially
converted into an outside passer
relative to these pawns and now we use
that pawn as a decoy we go d5 my
opponent won king a7 we push it all the
way forward forcing the king away and we
casually take the rest of black spawns
so a pretty simple concept protected
passers
equally as self-explanatory is passer
type three connected passers those are
two passers that are on adjacent uh
files also incredibly dangerous
protected sorry connected passers can
also be connected uh
i messed that up completely connected
passwords can also be protected this
will sound this will be easier to
understand once i make the moves let's
take a look at this example black has
tripled pawns the worst kind of passers
white has a situation a three on one in
which you can play c4
and after the trade
you have um connected passers and these
connected passers if you want
can be converted into also protected
passers with a d4 pawn protects the c5
fund you already know the mechanism
black's king has no choice but to go
back and forth because if it takes one
pawn the other pawn marches forward this
is entirely flexible you can invert this
and go d5 that's also fine whether you
want this or c5 depends on the position
of course or you can leave these pawns
be and what's great about
connected passers is that they often
create kind of a force field that keep
the enemy king away so you don't have to
convert them into protected passers you
can keep them in this kind of situation
where they are literally adjacent to
each other
um now white wins this by just taking
all of black's pawns and returning back
to supervise and guide these pawns home
okay type four gap tooth passers and i'm
kind of proud of this name i thought for
a while about how to call this i think
this accurately represents what these
pawns are these are pawns that are
located one file apart now you might say
well that's lame i prefer i would have
preferred that these pawns be on
adjacent files connected passers are
where it's at that's like a straight
flush
guess what gap tooth passers are often
not bad either
and the the easiest and the most
effective way of seeing that is to
examine a very important position what
happens when you have a gap-tooth pair
just against an enemy king it might seem
at first sight that black's king will be
able to just take both pawns at the same
time because they're not able to defend
each other and yet that is an illusion
white actually wins and these pawns are
able to be self-sufficient in much the
same way that connected and protected
passers are
what does white do here white can
actually well the simplest move is to
play a3
you set up a situation where the pawns
are one rank apart if black goes after
one pawn
the other pawn pushes can't take a3
because black white promotes okay okay
okay i'll go around i'll take this pawn
okay okay no no no no no we made a
mistake we played king f3 what we need
to do the moment the king reaches one
step away from taking the pawn the other
pawn pushes a4
and after king c5 you know the mechanism
you play a5 again they're one rank apart
again the black king can't take c4 and
the process keeps repeating don't forget
to play c5 c6 and we keep approaching uh
these pawns with our king and we win the
game at this point very easily
so gap tooth passers can be a great
asset as well
well what if we've widened the distance
between the gap
passers that leads us to type 5 and that
is one of my favorite types that is
trousers
and i introduced it in the previous
video trousers you can also call this
pants uh it's a term that i've only
heard in sort of the russian chess
lexicon stanley and trousers are
incredibly fearsome
you like two pant legs and these are two
pawns that are located three or more
files apart and most of the time we will
use this term to refer to pawns that are
basically on opposite sides of the board
this is often the most overpowered kind
of past pawn situation because obviously
the king cannot run to both directions
at the same time and so in terms of
making a queen this is often the safest
method we make one pass pawn the king
tries to stop it we can even push this
pawn to g5 and then we make the other
pass pawn and we have a trousers
situation the king cannot stop both at
the same time if it goes one way you
push the other pawn if it goes the other
way you push the b-pawn right king e6 g6
king f6 b5 you get the point you
generally give one of the pawns away the
other pawn promotes to
a queen
and those are the five types of special
pastors a lot of what we do a lot of
what we discuss is going to revolve in
one way or another
uh
about the sort of axis of these five
special types you have to master them
understand them and of course you have
to see how they fit into the framework
of pawn end games and that is what the
later videos
are going to be
dedicated to what we're going to do now
is examine a couple of
interesting examples relatively simple
examples where these past pawns where
these types are used and where we can
see the different methods of creating
pass bonds but first let me reiterate
the different types we have the outside
pass pawn let me see if i can remember
them we have the uh protected pass pawn
we have connected past pawns plural we
have gap tooth past pawns and we have
trousers
um or pants which are pawns that are on
either side of the board okay so let's
begin here
with an example let me flip the board
we're going to look at let me see how
many examples i have one two three
four five six seven i have seven
examples so
it's been already been 30 minutes let's
see if we can fit those into the next 15
minutes or so i don't want these videos
to be too long but again um if if you
have to go somewhere this is the part of
the video we've we've completed the sort
of theoretical part now we're going to
do a little bit
of practice and again i want to
reiterate here that these examples
you're about to see are relatively
simple
as you look at them you might say well
this isn't what the kinds of engines
that i get in my games and they're not
supposed to be patient we will look at
actual
long and elaborate pawn end games but
we're not there yet we need to cement
these concept concepts first
as an appetizer let's take a look at a
game of the great robert james fisher
bobby fischer who had the black pieces
in this position against
a strong master so it's black to play
now first thing you should see is that
black is up a pawn but white's king is
quite well placed it's attacking e5 and
you might also notice that the c4 pawn
is very weak and it's within reach of
the white king
so pause the video here
take
maybe a minute or two see if you can
find the very ingenious method with
which bobby won the game in just two
moves
okay
so a lot of people here i think would be
tempted to play f6 right defend the pawn
the problem with the move f6 is that
white runs to d5 notice that white has
the potential to create a past an
outside passer if he takes c4
and if we just sort of screw around
right if we just sort of i know king g5
well white takes on c4
and the issue is that if you like you
can now say wait a minute i can create a
passed pawn you play h4 you're actually
going to lose because by the time the
black is able to take this pawn white is
going to create a pass bond on the other
side of the board in fact the most
accurate move is king d5 king g3 king e4
white defends f3 and now white wins by
pushing these pawns and creating an
outside passer that doesn't work
now in this position you have a much
more efficient way of creating a
password you can play f5 and after b4
you can play f4
now i guess you could call this a type
of pawn breakthrough but it really isn't
it doesn't involve a sacrifice
there's a problem here after e takes f4
white is able to stop the h pawn white
is in time and if you play king takes a4
then white starts pushing his own pawn
a4 b5 you get a trait and you get a pawn
race which will be the subject of the
next video the pawns are running up the
board in tandem and you get this end
game which i haven't plugged this into
table bases but i think this is drawable
and even if it's not this is an
incredibly hard end game for black to
win so none of this seems convincing in
the least and the culprit is actually
the initial move rather than playing f6
fisher makes an absolutely genius move
he plays f5 check
what the heck this looks like it loses
on the spot he's just giving away the e5
fund what is he doing
well what he identified is that the
h-bond the idea of creating an outside
h-bond is correct
but the method of doing so was wrong
we shouldn't give up the c4 pawn and let
white do the same instead we give up the
e5 pawn we get our king to g5 and white
is in zug's bong a situation in which
essentially every move allows black to
push the f pawn to f4 and that is
because white doesn't have any good pawn
moves cardoso played a4 fischer
responded with a5 and now white is
officially in zug's long if you push the
b pawn black takes it if you push the f
bond black infiltrates the g4 takes g3
and then pushes the h pawn and if the
king steps away then black plays f4 this
is an outside passer it is unstoppable
the pawn count doesn't matter and black
wins the game so cardoso resigned after
the move a5 so a very nice little way of
using the outside passer and
understanding that
you often have to sacrifice bonds for
the greater good it's not about the
quality the quantity of passports about
the quality
next position
is from the career of olf anderson a
swedish grandmaster who is considered
one of the best end game players of all
time we will consider a lot of examples
from his career this is a pretty simple
one he has the white pieces here the
queens are still on the board and
anderson is trying to decide whether to
trade queens pause the video and try to
answer the question yourself
well the answer as you can probably
glean from the fact that this is a video
on pawn end games is yes you should
trade the queens but what do you do now
well we have one passport on h4
so if only we could have some trousers i
mean that would be nice but they're all
in the laundry we'll know there's one
that's clean we can play the move e4 e5
again technically this is a pawn
breakthrough but it's a very very simple
one the point is to get rid of the d6
pawn and black resigned immediately
because after fefe black has no choice
but to do something with the d-pawn d
takes c5 and a classic case of trousers
the e pawns are easily restrained by
white's king while white c and h months
are totally unrestrainable h5
c6 i mean this isn't even close
black can have several extra tempe and
he still wouldn't be able to catch the c
pawn
and so after e5 anderson's opponent the
grand master resigned the game simple
creation of trousers next position
okay
so uh this also comes from off
anderson's
career he's playing actually a very
strong international master and what
this example will show is that even the
strongest players make elementary
mistakes that stem from a lack of
understanding of how pawn end games and
frequently pass bonds work and this is
not meant to embarrass them i've made
many of those mistakes myself but it's a
very good idea to learn from those
mistakes now in this position anderson
has just played the move g4 what do you
notice
well
hopefully you notice that we have a type
of special pass bond we have a protected
passed pawn on d5 and it's protected by
an entire pawn chain which is the best
kind of protected passer right black has
absolutely no chance of ever winning
this pawn that black would have to go to
b2 and then capture all of these pawns
and so white has all of the time in the
world to do what he wants to do the
problem is that the the sort of entryway
is very very narrow and if black can
block it with this king you might get a
fortress situation where white cannot
make progress
so that's exactly what black was
thinking and black made the move g6 g5
this is a very instructive mistake it's
a decisive mistake that loses the game
now how would you describe why why do
you think this move is a mistake see if
you can verbalize it
well the reason it's a mistake is
because it black self deep freezes his
own pawns black creates a situation
where he can essentially never play h5
and create a password without allowing
trousers that unties white's hands and
allows him to make inroads through the
center the correct move was in fact to
create an outside password we have an
epic battle here of outside passer
versus connected passer and as it turns
out this battle ends in a dry it may
seem
uh particularly to those who are
experienced in the end game that white
is winning
why might it seem that white is winning
well you might think okay we're gonna go
king h3 we're gonna drag black's king
back as far away as possible and now
we're gonna use the decoy method we're
gonna play the move d6 drag black's king
toward the pawn and use our king to
essentially shoulder the black king all
the way out of his position so that we
can then take the pawns this is a method
that you will become intimately
acquainted with in a subsequent video
for now i'm going to kind of gloss over
it and you can slow the video down or
watch this part over again
to convince yourself that this is a
pretty simple method so black has to
stop the pawn we take h5
black takes our d-pawn and using
opposition we keep pushing the black
king away right king d7 king e5
king c6 king e6 we're pushing the way
kicking away pushing the king away and
i'm sure the black calculated up to this
point and thought i'm lost i'm going to
lose the c pawn and technically that's
not wrong but do you see the amazing
method that black can use to save the
game this is absolutely brilliant and
it's a very very important concept pause
the video and
really i want everybody watching the
video to find how black is able to save
the game
okay the way to save the game is to use
stalemate
you go king b6 king d6 and now king a5
this is one of my favorite defensive
ideas and you cannot take the pawn on c5
and you can but this is stalemate now
you might say well is it really
impossible to avoid stalemate well yes
it is because otherwise black just
toggles between these two squares and
the moment that you approach c6 b7 c5 at
stalemate obviously white can't push the
a pawn because black takes it or
onpassance it and
that's the end of the story that's it
there is simply nothing
that um
that can be done in this position
there's absolutely nothing that can be
done in this position black draws the
game so in most cases when you have a
connected sorry protected pass pawn
against an outside pass pawn the
protected pass pawn wins the battle
because uh well because it's protected
because essentially the enemy king has
to stay close to it while our king has a
much wider radius
right because it doesn't have to keep
the uh the pawn protected while an
outside pass pawn still needs to be
protected by the king right it's not
immune to capture
now how does g5 lose the game well
here's what happens anderson plays king
f3
black plays king f7 kingy forking f6
this is the situation that black was
relying on thinking well white cannot
make progress and here we use the decoy
method once again we go d6
d7 distracting the black hang and now
which way do you go
well it might be tempting to go this way
because it looks like white is able to
capture both pawns and create an outside
passer and but that's an illusion if you
actually calculate after king d6 king g6
king e5 white actually loses the game
king takes h6 king f14 h5 and now black
has a waiting move a5 the subject of
another video
on extra and or waiting moves and white
is in zuma's you got to move the king
relinquishing the g4 pawn so that's not
the right way to go
but remember we've got the black pawns
in a deep freeze we don't need to go
this way we can go this way we can go
king d5 this pawn is perfectly capable
of taking care of the other two pawns
bla white simply takes on c
and now it's time to simply push our
passer that's it we don't have to pay
attention to the to the king side at all
and if black plays h5 and g4 we can just
stop the pawn
and uh anderson won after c6 black
resigned because after king d8 king d6
king c8 c7 black has nothing better than
now to push and you might say wait a
minute well we can't stop black's pawn
but it doesn't take long to realize
hopefully that white can push his own
pawn
and we promote with check and we win
the game so a great illustration of a
strong player not appreciating how the
notion of deep freezing uh can really
hurt your chances
um okay
so let's continue
with a an example from the great t grand
petrossian the world champion and again
we don't start with the pawn end game
but we will get there very quickly so
petrossian has the white pieces here
he's got a great position he's got a
beautiful knight on f6 he's threatening
to infiltrate and his opponent finds a
very ingenious idea and that's the move
knight f7 to h6
and the idea is to get this knight over
to f5 to an active square
and if white takes on h6 then black
takes the knight and then as liebert was
probably calculating h7 rookie eight and
black is able to stop the pawn
everything looks pretty hunky-dory here
but petrossian saw one step further than
his opponent and petrosian forces the
rook trade with the move rook a3 to e3
okay well how do we evaluate this pawn
end game
well the way that we evaluate the spawn
end game is by understanding that white
has an outside passer and the fact that
this outside password is a weakness
doesn't matter the fact that it exists
is a lot more important black has no
choice but to go around and try to
capture it and in this position all that
remains is to figure out a way to make
inroads into black's position and this
is where we apply a simple pawn trade we
play the move f5
notice that if black plays g5 we
establish gap-toothed pawns which means
the black king cannot go in either
direction and then we easily capture
black spawn and win the game so black
has to go king h7 that's a nice
defensive move
now the move f6 would be a huge mistake
because the pawn is restrained and black
gets trousers
so instead petrosian takes
and now petrosian makes an incredibly
important move you might be very tempted
to play h7 and king f5 right going
around and taking all of flax pawns but
it's not that simple after king g7 king
e6 black has a hidden defensive resource
and it technically again is a pawn
breakthrough black has the move b6 b5
cb and now d5 and guess what all of a
sudden black creates a protected
passpond and because it's protected
black has the time to walk to the other
side of the board with his king and save
a draw and you can trust me on this
in the interest of time we won't go all
the way down this variation but this is
a draw and so for that reason in this
position the trojan has to play in a
much more careful and ingenious way how
do we prevent black from creating an
outside protected passer well we do that
by literally putting a pawn in the way
we go b4 b5 that's all that you need to
do king takes h6 king f5 and now
everything works perfectly because if
black plays d5 you simply take it and
after cd this is no longer protected you
take this pawn you come around and you
use the king capture method to create uh
a set of two passports to promote them
so
this example shows the power of outside
past spawns but it also shows us that we
can never fall asleep on our opponent's
potential uh passpond creation ideas
even if the king is not involved
pawns on in and of themselves on their
own can be incredibly powerful and
you're going to continue to see this as
we explore uh various examples now
again in the interest of time i can see
that the video has been going for 45
minutes
i'm planning to show three more examples
but uh again we're gonna cut cut off two
of them and we're going to assign them
to a later video again this is
i'm exploring here right i don't know
how long any of this will take this is
all still exploratory so please forgive
me uh if if the pacing isn't exactly
isn't exactly what you imagined it to be
so let me see which example
i i want to give you this is one of them
this is another one let's um
let me think for a second this one
this is a carlson game this is a great
position but still this is a little
outside the scope this one i can just
show you really quickly basically the
idea in this example
uh is to play the move g5 check and
create a deep freeze situation against
the black pawns right that's basically
all it is and a little bit later on in
the game white creates a gap-toothed
pawn situation the pawns are basically
self-sufficient and you're able to use
your king to win both of black's pawn so
this is a pretty self-explanatory
example
um
this is the one i want to talk about and
it's not because it comes from one of my
games it's just because this is a bit of
a segue into
the larger context of things
because this is a bit of a longer pawn
end game and it might not be immediately
apparent who's winning here or what to
do so it's white to play
and what you should notice here is that
you have a
pawn majority situation white is a four
on three
and black has a three on two
and in these kinds of situations
what people very often do is they focus
too much on creating a past pawn and not
enough on positioning your king properly
to that end if you play the move c4 you
allow black's king to infiltrate to the
center and that is a huge concession
because now your pawns are no longer
moving right black has frozen them with
this king
instead it is crucial to first play the
move king d4 stopping king e5
my opponent starts pushing his pawns
i start pushing mine i play c4
and my idea is of course to create a
pass pawn and then to distract black's
king and walk over to the king's side
and that's basically exactly what
happens b6 stopping c5 so we reinforce
the threat b4
black plays a5
we trade and we go c5 this is all very
simple so far but after a4 the critical
moment arises
so
the tempting idea is of course to play
d6 right create the past pawn king e6
distract black's king and it looks like
white's winning right at first sight it
looks like we're gonna take all of
black's pawns but this is where pawn end
games are often so deceptive right you
can't forget about the fact again that
pawns can be self-sufficient and the
problem is that if you go king g6 you
allow black now to create an unstoppable
passer and if you waste time with the
move h3
then black is basically in time to take
this pawn and win the pawn race you can
trust me on that and so amazingly it
turns out that this entirely natural
move d6 turns out to be a mistake
and instead of this we have to violate a
rule right understand that everything i
say is to be taken in context and one of
the beautiful aspects of endings in my
opinion is that sometimes the rules have
to be bent or violated and in this case
what i realized is that i need a pawn
that's as far away as possible from the
king side that's the only way i can
properly distract black's king so the
correct passer here is not the d-pawn
and i've been telling you this whole
time the perspective passer is the one
which has no direct obstructions but
here you need to use the method of king
assistance to create a past c pawn and
therefore the correct move is c6 now
this threatens a simple pawn
breakthrough it threatens d6 followed by
c7 black's king has to move back and
here you already reap the fruits of your
labor you get your king into e5
now you freeze black's pawns with h3
and it turns out funnily enough that you
don't even need to create a passport the
threat of creating a passpond is what
you need this already forces black's
king back and that's all you need now
you go king f5 and now you're in time to
capture all of black's pawns and by the
time black captures your pawns you get a
classic uh outside password situation my
opponent resigned here because this is
simple enough after king d5 you go king
f5
and what's funny about this is that you
don't win this in the traditional method
you win this and this will segue us
nicely into the next video that's why i
ended with this example
because we have a pawn race who wins the
pawn race
well white wins the pawn race only
because we promote with a check and you
might say whoa how did i see all that
how did i know all of that you'll have
to wait until the next video on pawn
races where i will explain everything
about these types of end games where
both sides have a past pawn and there is
no king activity involved the past pawns
are just marching forward to promotion
how do you be the one uh how do you make
sure that you're the one to win uh pawn
races
so this is a great example of where it's
all about creating a passpond that's as
far away as possible from uh the pawns
that you ultimately want to capture and
these are the examples that i want to
show
in this video i will carry the other
examples over to a subsequent video
where we will kind of put everything
together
oh my goodness what a whirlwind journey
we just went through we're 50 minutes in
so if you're still here if you're still
watching i really really appreciate it
now this is on the longer side and this
gives me important context as to how to
pace the subsequent videos a little
summary what did we talk about we
defined past pawns we talked about what
they are what they aren't past pawns
pawns that have no enemy pawns in front
of them or in front of them and adjacent
on the file adjacent to them that's
simple enough
we discussed uh several methods of
creating pass pawns the king capture
method in particular
and uh
the pawn advance method where you use
pawns to create pass pawn we discussed
the ppp rule uh push the prospective
pastor much of the time we discussed the
dangers of allowing a deep freeze where
one
pawn
or a pawn minority is essentially
dominating a pawn majority we discussed
how hard it can be to create passers in
a three-on-two scenario uh but the fact
that the ppp rule mostly still applies
then we transitioned uh to using the
king one more way of creating a password
using your king to push uh upon majority
and then we transition to the five types
of passers of course we have the outside
past pawn
uh the protected past pawn connected
pass pawns gap tooth pass pawns and uh
finally
trousers or pants and then of course
there are pawns that pass bonds that
don't fall into any of these categories
if black had a pass pawn for example you
might say well what what do i mean by
that well what i mean by that is for
example let me just uh
so for instance
and where was the example i wanted to
show
not this one up this way i think it
might be this one no not this one
it's this one so so the c5 pawn
in this situation is neither right it
doesn't fall into any of the types it's
not an outside pass spawn because it's
much closer to the other pawns right so
most pawns are like the c5 pawn and
that's why you have to isolate and
understand each of the five types so
remember the five types protected past
pawns connected pass pawns trousers and
then we moved on to application we
examined several cases in the fischer
game uh black demonstrated the
importance of outside pass pawns in the
anderson game white created a trousers
situation in the um anderson second game
black failed to appreciate how dangerous
the deep freeze can be in the petrossian
game white again used an outside pass
pawn and then blocked black from
creating a protective pass spawn
and finally in my game i kind of
violated the rule of past pawn creation
i realized that i have to create a
passpond that's as far away as possible
from
the other
pawns
and of course there are so many more
examples to examine but don't be
discouraged we will look at them we will
have many many more pawn end game
interactions but i think this is a good
place to stop i hope this gives you good
context on past pawns and helps you
understand how they fit in the overall
context the next video will be about
pawn races and i hope to record it
within the next day or two please feel
free to leave honest feedback uh again
this is a series in production this is
just the start and i want to make this
better and better as i go along so thank
you everybody so much for listening and
for watching and for the wholesome
uh support and positive feedback thank
you everybody and i'll see you in the
next video
[Music]